depuis des années antoine hébert sheller
souhaitait partager son amour pour la
cuisine béganne mais ce n'est qu'en
juillet dernier que ce professeur
d'histoire géographie et sa femme karima
se lance dans cette aventure à mi temps
les deux passionnés ont depuis développé
un fast-food vegan à emporter à bois
d'arcy le premier dans les yvelines
ça fait longtemps qu'on a dans nos
habitudes on a réduit énormément les
tous les produits d'origine animale et
on est très contents des petits plats
des petits menus conséquence faire des
hamburgers à la maison est végétarien
avec des frites ou des kebabs et on
s'est dit mais pourquoi pas faire
partager ce plaisir
aux autres en faisant un petit service
de restauration rapide vegan c'est après
un accident qui aurait pu mal tourner
quand one et karima décide d'ouvrir le
service de restauration rapide
on a eu un incendie chez nous donc tout
sept états l'a été ravagés et on s'est
dit peut-être le moment de reconstruire
on va en profiter pour lancer le projet
ici donc pas de viande mais des simili
carnet des fausses vianne à base de
protéines de soja de blé ou de poids
l'objectif est de diminuer leur
consommation pour limiter l'empreinte
environnementale
c'est les valeurs qu'on défend donc les
valeurs c'est la santé et la planète et
sait où c'est une façon de proposer une
alternative et aider les gens qui
veulent faire une transiteront une
transition nos produits font font penser
à de la viande quoi donc ceux qui
veulent retrouver les plaisirs de la
viande est entré et j'ai envie de dire
en précisant une viande de très bonne
qualité gustative et nutritionnelle
on est là pour répondre à cette demande
là
au menu kebab hot-dogs burger ou une
formule à 12 euros
en attendant la réouverture en septembre
les deux géants s'offrent quelques jours
de repos bien mérité à la rentrée
antoine souhaite continuer son emploi de
professeur tout en ouvrant une à deux
fois par semaine